hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be a timeline explainer for the
reverse-flash and an explainer for why
he is unkillable in the sense of the
comics now there is comic book deaths
and there is true death
so the reverse-flash baryons they've all
died many times and come back because
surprise surprise comic book logic it's
the most fun thing ever so all these
scenes will explain where he started on
the flash the original version of the
character starting in season 1 - now at
the end of legends of tomorrow so what
I'll do is I'll put a spoiler warning
before we get to the legends of tomorrow
stuff later in the video and a little
bit of text to explain when we change
from one version of reverse flash to
another and then at the very end of this
I'll put it all into context and explain
what's going on in the future of the
flash season 3 how barry will continue
to fight reverse flash champion Daleks
some would say I'm the reverse
usually your reverse-flash you and I
have never been truly properly
introduced
I am your guard pond so
like Eddie let's call him a distant
relative just so we're clear how do I
kill you I'm going to kill them and then
I'm going to kill your father
I hold sway
he's being ranked from existence
I've controlled your life for so long
Mary will you get along without me
[Applause]
Barry we need you back here stat all
right I'm on my way
[Music]
Gideon the truth you think I'm [ __ ]
fun I believe it was I finally figured
out what time period the flash is from
now let's figure out a way to get home
this is now here today this is a time
song comes from this is the moment you
are erased from existence but since dawn
is from the future this is where his
timeline begins that's why he's still
alive this dawn has not yet traveled
back in time to kill Barry's mother he's
here now in this time period for the
first time timeline remnant explains
where nothing's changed yeah it also
explains why he didn't know my name or
that we have met before to him you
hadn't until the future if Thawne dies
before he can time travel again will
that save Barry's mother's no style
works you know in timeline Barry's
mother's already dead and her death is a
fixed point nothing can change that
is that you
flash why do you hate me so much I
didn't always
I was obsessed with him for so long I
wanted to be the flash
I spent years figuring out how you came
to be duplicated the reaction it worked
I became like you
so what happened this ability to travel
through time revealed the truth my fate
was to become your greatest enemy I was
never going to be the flash so I became
the reverse of everything that you were
the more people you saved the more you
were loved and more I had to take from
you
we'll meet again soon flash I know my
father's taken for me I need to find
some peace whatever you need to do do it
you're not going to do never again no
[Music]
too busy leading your reverse it's a
wonderful life reverse huh adds irony
for you so what should we call this
brave new world that you've whipped up
for us I was thinking flashpoint so you
don't want this I am the answer to all
your prayers all you need to do is ask
me Barry we need to go back in time
until that night to do what you know
what I need you to do yeah
there we go things are back to how they
should be well for me anyway for you
well
I guess you'll just have to wait and
find out what what does that mean see
some time soon flash I need you as much
as you need me all right but if you do
not open that door he is going to kill
us he is coming for me who's coming for
you it's not a who it's a of what I
think one of the things and you feel a
little more specific my ancestor killed
himself in an effort to erase my very
existence wow you're pretty spry despite
it the flash pulled me from the timeline
he held me captive for months and what I
finally got loose I found myself pursued
by something a guy I thought it was a
time race the monsters that hunt
speedsters who messed with time but
whatever is hunting me
Farah worse than the time race
it can sense the speedforce
it's trying to kill me
can't believe we made it don't jinx it
sorry Jason Varitek
[Music]
not that guy these guy
you traveled back in time to help
yourselves I figured I could do the same
it's true what they say if you want
something done right you really have to
do it yourself
I'm going to drive this through your
heart yeah about that
[Music]
so I know it seems like reverse flashes
dead on legends of tomorrow but that's
really just the time remnant that
originally started at the beginning or
the middle of flash season 2 so the
original version of the character ends
up dying during the season 1 finale but
then the time remnant comes back during
season 2 so this is where he becomes a
Time revenant and continues to exist and
come back during flashpoint because
that's when he comes back to kill
Barry's mother Barry stops him and they
both become the flashpoint versions of
themselves so this version that Barry
whisks away and takes Back to the Future
with him is still the original time
remnant from season 2 they both enjoy
flashpoint then he has him reverse
flashpoint by killing his mother again
then he chuckles his evil laugh again
and says see you soon again Barry as he
is just enjoying what Barry's going to
find out has changed what's different
about flashpoint so this version of the
reverse flash is still the time revenant
he goes on to legends of tomorrow to try
and start binding the spear of destiny
to fix things so that the black flash
will stop trying to chase him down and
erase him from existence so if you were
confused about which version of eobard
thought died on legends of tomorrow it's
the original time remnant version from
way back in season 2 he's effectively
unchanged remember he didn't use his
speed force powers during flashpoint
like Barry so he has way more memories
of what happened before then Barry does
Barry started to lose some of his
memories but the thing is is that during
the legends of tomorrow finale when he
goes to different points in his timeline
and grabs more time remanence 2 xored
the spear of destiny he doesn't get
every single version of himself so
there's still other time remnants that
could always come back and here's the
big reason why you can't kill the
reverse-flash while he's still alive out
there somewhere because he and barry
still have to have all those future
adventures fighting each other that he
talked about we know each other from the
future we've been fighting each other
for years
so Barry learns about this during season
1 season 2 season 3 but this is the
younger version of the character so we
haven't seen any of those future battles
that they've had they still have to have
those meaning that a version of reverse
flash is still alive too
like the flash in the future so there
will always be a version of
reverse-flash that's alive it is a
question of which version of the
character the actor who's playing the
character right now just said time to
hang this up for a little while he
didn't save forever so the reverse-flash
will come back we might not see him
again till the next season of the flash
I'm not expecting him on the flash
season 3 again but usually when they
kill a character in such a big way like
this they don't bring him right back so
just don't expect reverse flash til
season 4 of the flash in whatever he
comes back he's not supposed to be the
big bill and they said the season 4 main
villain on the flash will not be a
speedster so hopefully that explains the
reverse flash between the flash season 1
season 3 in legends of tomorrow so he's
still alive out there somewhere in the
timeline and there's always the
multiverse explainer - there's still
infinite numbers of eobard thawne's
on other earth there's even one on
cara's earth that we haven't met yet
that would actually be fantastic so
here's my big question for you when they
bring him back what kind of story do you
want them to use him for we still need
to see his origin story he narrated it
he talked about how he reverse
engineered the accident that gave
Barry's powers so it would be really fun
to see that code out to see a look into
the 25th century where he's from now in
the comics is a little bit different but
they're usually true to the core of the
character even if they change minor
details but if you're big fan of the
character they just brought him back in
the flash rebirth comic so if you want
to read the comics you can read a whole
bunch of eobard thawne in the next
couple of months congratulations to the
last giveaway winner caleb Cheetham
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details it was a new round that
started in this video while you wait for
that you can click here for brand new
flash and you can click here for that
marvel defenders teaser
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys in the next
video